From WBEZ Chicago, it's This American Life , distributed by Public Radio International. I'm David Rakoff, sitting in for Ira Glass.
来自芝加哥WBEZ电台，这是《美国生活》，由国际公共广播电台发行。我是大卫·拉科夫，代班伊拉·格拉斯。
There was an old cartoon, it was either in the New Yorker or National Lampoon , I can't remember, where a man is sitting on the bus. It's pretty empty. An odd stranger boards, and the man in the seat thinks to himself, "Oh, God. Please don't let him sit beside me. Oh God. Please don't let him sit beside me." The guy approaches and says, "God told me to sit beside you."
有个老卡通，我不记得是在《纽约客》还是《国家讽刺》杂志上看到的，画的是一个人坐在公交车上。车厢很空。一个奇怪的陌生人上了车，坐在位子上的人心想：“天哪，千万别让他坐我旁边。天哪，千万别让他坐我旁边。”那人走过来，说：“上帝告诉我，要坐在你旁边。”
In the spring of 1978, I was 13 years old. The local public high school that I would be attending in a year's time was having an evening screening of Casablanca. So I took my friend Jeff and we went off to the high school.
1978年春天，我13岁。我一年后即将入读的当地公立高中在举办一场《卡萨布兰卡》的晚间放映会。于是我叫上朋友杰夫，一起去了那所高中。
In addition to my love of old movies and my general cluelessness about popular music and youth culture, I was also a really tiny child. Maybe five feet at time. Probably closer to for four foot eight. So I looked markedly different from other kids my age.
除了热爱老电影以及对流行音乐和青年文化一窍不通之外，我还是个特别瘦小的孩子。当时大概只有5英尺高，可能更接近4英尺8英寸。所以我看起来和同龄人明显不同。
I was also a little neurotic. I was riddled with phobias. It all served to make me seem a little odd, I'm sure. I didn't lack friends, but I was a strange, round-limbed, feminine little kid. A strange, round-limbed, feminine little kid for whom a screening of Casablanca at the high school, no less, was a fairly important event.
我还稍微有点神经质。我患有各种恐惧症。我相信，这一切都让我显得有点古怪。我不缺朋友，但我是一个奇怪的、四肢圆润的、女性化的小男孩。一个奇怪的、四肢圆润的、女性化的小男孩，对他来说，在高中礼堂看一场《卡萨布兰卡》是一件相当重要的事情。
If I think about it, I guess the fantasy going through my head was that I would meet other old movie buffs who would see past my juvenile exterior and into my very poet's soul. And then I would have, you know, a community of people who didn't care that I was dwarfish or 13. Maybe we would smoke and talk about films.
回想起来，我当时脑子里的幻想是，我会遇到其他老电影迷，他们能透过我孩子气的外表，看到我那充满诗意的灵魂。然后，我就会拥有一个不在乎我像侏儒或者只有13岁的朋友圈子。也许我们会抽着烟，谈论电影。
Jeff and I were the only ones who showed up. The only two people in the auditorium, aside from two older boys at the back on a ladder who were taping up some banner of some sort or another.
杰夫和我是仅有的观众。礼堂里只有我们两个人，除了后面梯子上有两个大男孩，正忙着贴某种横幅。
So the lights are still on and we're waiting for the movie to start. And I hear one of the boys on the ladder call my name. "David! David!"
灯还没关，我们等着电影开始。我听到梯子上的其中一个男孩在叫我的名字。“大卫！大卫！”
If you're a gay kid, or even just a gay-ish kid, you basically spend your life anticipating having the crap beaten out of you, or at the very least, being given what used to be known on Leave It to Beaver as "The Business." I didn't know this guy calling my name. I knew that much. He wasn't a friend of my brother's or my sister's. I knew, actually, two things with complete certainty-- one, that I wasn't the David that he was calling for, and two, that if I did turn around, he would give me "The Business." So I didn't turn around.
如果你是一个男同性恋小孩，或者仅仅是一个看起来像同性恋的小孩，你基本上一辈子都在预感自己会挨揍，或者至少，会被像《海狸小姐》里常说的那样“被修理一顿”。我不认识这个叫我名字的人。这一点我很确定。他不是我兄弟或姐妹的朋友。事实上，我非常确定两件事——第一，他叫的不是我这个大卫；第二，如果我回头，他肯定会“修理”我。所以我没有回头。
But it just went on and on. Him was calling my name and nobody else being in the auditorium. After about a quarter of an hour, against my better judgment, thinking, perhaps, that there had been some wrinkle in the space-time continuum, and maybe this older guy did somehow know me after all-- there was no one else in the auditorium and he kept on calling "David! David!" So eventually I turned around and I said, "Yes?"
但他没完没了地叫。他一直在叫我的名字，而礼堂里又没有别人。大约一刻钟后，我违背了理智，心想也许时空连续体出现了偏差，或许这个大个子真的认识我——礼堂里再没别人，而他一直在叫“大卫！大卫！”于是，最终我转过身，说：“什么事？”
It was as if I could see the words coming out of his mouth, printed like a speech bubble in a comic, moving through the air towards me as if the entire atmosphere was viscous. Moving as slowly towards me as a bubble traveling through liquid Prell. And I knew, I knew what the words would be before they even reached my ears!
那一刻，我就好像能看见那些字从他嘴里吐出来，像漫画里的气泡框一样印在空中，向我飘来，仿佛整个大气层都变得黏稠了。移动的速度像气泡穿过洗发水一样缓慢。而在这些字传到我耳朵里之前，我就已经知道，我知道它们会是什么！
"David! David!" "Yes?" "Not you, you fag!" Of course, that was what he said.
“大卫！大卫！”“什么事？”“不是叫你，你个死基佬！”当然，他就是这么说的。
I had thought that the unforeseen bonanza of the evening was that I was going to be somehow enfolded, all four feet eight inches of me, into some Bohemian clique, when in fact, what I should have seen was this. If I hadn't turned around, he probably would have just gotten down from the ladder anyway, and walked over to me, tapped me on the shoulder, and called me a fag. "God told me to sit beside you."
我曾以为今晚意想不到的收获是，我这4英尺8英寸的躯体将以某种方式融入一个波西米亚小圈子，而实际上，我早该料到会这样。如果我不回头，他大概也会从梯子上下来，走到我面前，拍拍我的肩膀，骂我一声基佬。“上帝告诉我，要坐在你旁边。”
Hope might spring eternal, dread might loom like a dark cloud on the horizon. Sometimes, regardless of your action or inaction, half-empty, half-full, some things in this life are just bound to happen.
希望或许永存，恐惧或许如地平线上的阴云般笼罩。有时，无论你采取行动与否，无论这杯水是半空还是半满，生活中的某些事注定会发生。
Today on our show-- stories of inevitability. Those things that will happen, like it or not. Our show today in four acts.
今天节目里，我们将讲述关于不可避免性的故事。那些无论你喜欢与否，都注定会发生的事情。今天的节目分为四幕。
Act One, If It Drives, Go Live. A true crime story about the world's most law-abiding perp ever to receive four hours of continuous live news coverage.
第一幕，《只要能开，就去直播》。一个真实犯罪故事，关于史上最守法的逃犯，他竟然获得了长达四个小时的现场新闻直播报道。
Act Two, Don't Just Stand There. You can't change the people you love even when your life might depend on it.
第二幕，《别只是站在那儿》。即便生活可能取决于此，你依然无法改变你所爱的人。
Act Three, Hello, Baby. How to prepare yourself for one of life's greatest inevitabilities, like it and not, with little more than a wobbly movie projector and a breathing chart.
第三幕，《你好，宝贝》。如何准备迎接人生中最不可避免的一刻——无论你是否喜欢，仅凭一台晃晃悠悠的电影放映机和一张呼吸图表。
Act Four, On the Eighth Day, God Created Tartar Sauce. How mother nature, in an act of pure generosity, annually lays out the world's greatest all-you-can-eat raw bar on a small beach in Alabama. Stay with us, won't you?
第四幕，《第八天，上帝创造了塔塔酱》。大自然母亲如何以慷慨之举，每年在阿拉巴马州的一处小沙滩上铺开世界上最棒的“畅吃”生食吧。请继续收听，好吗？
Act One. If It Drives, Go Live.
第一幕，《只要能开，就去直播》。
If you get into a car chase with the police, you pretty much know how it's going to end. 90% to 95% of the time, you will be caught. Despite, or perhaps because of this, car chases have become an increasingly popular staple of TV news programming. Viewers have watched people try to elude the cops in various ways, like plowing through a crowded pedestrian malls. They've even seen a fleeing suspect attempt a carjacking. Starlee Kine has the story of the latest incarnation of the continuously televised car chase that answers the question, why did they run if they know they're going to get caught? And why do we watch?
如果你和警察发生飞车追逐，你大概知道结局会怎样。90%到95%的情况下，你会落网。尽管如此——或者正是因为如此——飞车追逐已成为电视新闻中越来越受欢迎的常态。观众已经看过人们试图用各种方式躲避警察，比如冲进拥挤的步行街。他们甚至看过逃跑的嫌疑人试图劫车。斯塔莉·基恩带来了这个最新持续电视直播追逐战的故事，它回答了这样一个问题：如果他们知道自己会被抓，为什么要逃？而我们为什么又要看？
In Los Angeles, on August 31, 2001, all other news and KCAL 9 was interrupted in order to bring you this car chase.
2001年8月31日，洛杉矶KCAL 9台中断了所有新闻，为你带来这场飞车追逐。
And the pursuit continues. And I believe we're north of the airport now. Larry Welk?
追逐还在继续。我想我们现在在机场北边。拉里·韦尔克？
Yeah. Back with you here. This suspect has been going on now for over three hours now, well over three hours. Almost four now. With showing no signs of giving up, no signs of stopping.
是的，回到这儿。这个嫌疑人已经开了超过三个小时了，远不止三个小时。快四个小时了。没有任何放弃的迹象，没有任何停下的迹象。
This, of course, would have been no big deal, since in LA, there's car chases on TV all the time. And really, this one is no different than your basic high-speed police pursuit-- except for that speed part.
当然，这本来没什么大不了的，因为在洛杉矶，电视上到处都是飞车追逐。说实话，这次和普通的高速警匪追逐没什么不同——除了速度这一点。
The suspect still driving well within the speed limit. In fact, lower than the speed limit. Driving very reasonably right now through the streets of southern California.
嫌疑人依然在限速内行驶。事实上，比限速还要低。开得非常稳，穿过南加州的街道。
And the police part.
还有警察的部分。
There's nobody else behind him right now. Everybody has pulled off, including the LAPD, Hawthorne, Inglewood. They are not there. Nowhere to be seen.
现在他身后一个人也没有。所有人都退出了，包括洛杉矶警察局、霍桑警局、英格尔伍德警局。他们都不在那儿。踪影全无。
Oh. And the pursuit part.
噢。还有追逐的部分。
You know, at this point, the officers are saying that they have a really good idea of who he is. They have a pretty good idea of where he lives, even. And so at this point, they're going to go ahead and let him drive home, if that's what he wants to do.
你知道，现在警察说他们基本知道他是谁了。他们甚至大概知道他住哪儿。所以现在，他们决定让他开车回家，如果他想的话。
On Thursday, August 31, 2001, viewers of KCAL were told they were watching a car chase. But what they were actually watching was a white Geo Prizm driving slowly up and down residential streets, stopping at every stop sign, and signalling every time he wanted to turn, with no police behind him. If you tuned in the day with the sound off, you'd be wondering why it was on TV at all.
2001年8月31日星期四，KCAL的观众被告知他们在看一场飞车追逐。但他们实际看到的是一辆白色Geo Prizm在住宅区街道慢慢地开，在每个停车标志前停下，转弯时还打转向灯，后面根本没有警车。如果你那天静音观看，你一定会纳闷这为什么能上电视。
Of course, if you had the sound on, you were probably even more confused, because the image on the screen had very little to do with what was coming out of the news announcer's mouth. It was as though they weren't looking at the screen at all, but were instead reciting their lines for memory, drawing from all the past car chases they covered.
当然，如果你开了声音，你可能会更困惑，因为屏幕上的画面和新闻主播嘴里说的话几乎毫无关联。他们看起来根本没在看屏幕，而是在背诵台词，借鉴以往所有报道过的飞车追逐案例。
The car chase began normally enough. At around six o'clock, the car's driver pulled a hit and run. It was a minor fender bender and no one got hurt, but he took off anyway. The LAPD tried to pull him over, but he refused. They chased him for a few hours before finally deciding to stop.
飞车追逐开始得很正常。大约六点，车主肇事逃逸了。只是个轻微的剐蹭，没人受伤，但他还是跑了。洛杉矶警察局试图让他靠边停车，但他拒绝了。他们追了他几个小时，最终决定放弃。
In the past couple of years, many police departments have begun to rethink their strategies when it comes to chasing. If a suspect doesn't seem like an immediate threat, the police will often pull out, or try to get his license plate number so they can arrest him later, reasoning that the risk of hurting innocent bystanders in a car chase is greater than the risk of letting a guy who ran a red light get away.
过去几年里，许多警察局开始重新思考追逐策略。如果嫌疑人看起来没有直接威胁，警察通常会撤出，或者设法记下车牌号以便以后逮捕，理由是在飞车追逐中伤害无辜路人的风险，远大于让一个闯红灯的人逃脱的风险。
At the time of this chase though, this was still a relatively new procedure that most people had never seen before.
但在那场追逐时，这还是个大多数人从未见过的新程序。
We were in shock. We were saying, wait a minute? What's going on here? They're letting this guy go.
我们当时惊呆了。我们说，等等？这是怎么回事？他们居然放他走。
This is Larry Welk, the KCAL helicopter pilot whose voice you've been hearing.
这就是拉里·韦尔克，你刚才一直听到的KCAL直升机飞行员。
And it was tough to be on TV and explain to people what was happening. Because we had this pursuit going on, then the police pulled up, and it's almost like the news story just went away. Well, what are we doing here now?
在电视上向人们解释发生什么事很难。因为我们正在报道这场追逐，然后警察撤了，新闻好像突然就没了。好吧，我们现在在干什么？
That was indeed the question. With their top story called off right under their very noses, the KCAL news team suddenly found themselves in the unique position of being the only one following this guy around. But rather than turn to another story, the station decides to stick with this one.
这确实是个问题。头条新闻在眼皮底下被叫停，KCAL新闻团队发现自己处于一种独特的境地，成为唯一在跟踪这家伙的人。但车站决定不换话题，而是坚持报道下去。
And it's around this point that the situation goes from being merely baffling to truly absurd, when the newscasters begin floundering for things to say. In fact, right about here.
就在这个时候，情况从令人困惑变得真正荒谬了，新闻主播们开始为该说什么而挣扎。事实上，就在这儿。
I guess one thing we've certainly learned-- this is a fuel-efficient car. I guess just the kind you want to have in a pursuit. And forgive me if I'm making light of the situation. I'm not trying to do that and you guys know that. But for goodness sakes, this has gone on, as you say, for four hours now, and he has not run out of gas yet. So that says a lot about the vehicle he's driving.
我想我们肯定学到了一点——这车真省油。我想这正是追逐战中你想要的车型。原谅我如果我对局势有些轻描淡写。我不是有意的，你们也知道。但看在上帝的份上，这都已经持续了四个小时了，他还没耗光汽油。这对他开的车说明了很多。
The chase even survives a shift change.
这场追逐甚至熬过了换班时间。
We are going to stay with this case, so stay with us. There is another hour of news ahead.
我们将继续报道这个案件，请留在我们频道。还有一小时的新闻在后面。
[UNINTELLIGIBLE] and Gary standing by. KCAL 9 news at 10 starts right now.
[听不清]和加里待命。KCAL 9点新闻现在开始。
And thank you, Dave [? Cillia. ?] A pursuit that continues right now only by air. Ground units have completely pulled out.
谢谢你，戴夫·[？西里亚。]追逐现在仅通过空中进行。地面部队已完全撤出。
KCAL is a local independent station. In addition to news, it also airs shows like People's Court and Family Feud . They usually show one car chase about every two weeks, and the effects on the ratings are dramatic. On a typical day, about 400,000 people tune in to KCAL's nightly news programming. The numbers quadruple once a car chase comes on. And when the chases are over, the numbers drop back down again. Here's the helicopter pilot, Larry Welk.
KCAL是一家地方独立电台。除了新闻，也播《人民法庭》和《家庭问答》之类的节目。他们通常每两周播一次飞车追逐，收视率效果惊人。平时，大约有40万人收看KCAL的晚间新闻。一旦有飞车追逐，数字就会翻四倍。追逐一结束，数字又掉回去了。这是直升机飞行员拉里·韦尔克。
Are there other car chases that don't make the cut?
有没有没能上电视的飞车追逐？
Not really. If we [UNINTELLIGIBLE] had a car chase, for the most part, it'll make it on TV.
没有。如果我们[听不清]有飞车追逐，大部分情况都能上电视。
Do you watch car chases?
你看飞车追逐吗？
I'm embarrassed to say that I do. I not only watch the car chases, but I yell at the television screen while it's going on, as though I'm covering it. When the guy blows a red light, "Oh no, look out!"  You know? And my wife comes in. She'll be doing the laundry, and she'll walk in and watch me watching a chase, and she'll shake your head and say, "What in the world are you doing? Go take out the garbage." I mean, there could be a pursuit that runs through our backyard and she wouldn't care.
我不好意思说我看了。我不光看，我还会对着电视机大喊大叫，好像我在报道一样。当那家伙闯红灯时，“噢不，小心！”你知道吗？我妻子进来时。她本来在洗衣服，走进来看到我在看追逐，她会摇摇头说：“你到底在干嘛？去把垃圾倒了。”我是说，就算追逐从我们后院经过，她都不会在乎。
But I'm one of those guys that watches pursuits. It's cops and robbers. You watch these guys getting chased, and you don't know what's happening next. And that's what keeps you glued. And you're afraid-- I'm afraid to go to the bathroom. I'm afraid to go get a glass of water. Because I'm afraid that when I walk out of the room, the guy's going to pull a Dukes of Hazzard and jump over a bridge or something.
但我就是那种会看追逐的人。这是猫捉老鼠。你看着这些家伙被追，你不知道接下来会发生什么。这就是让你目不转睛的原因。我怕——我怕去洗手间。我怕去接杯水。因为我怕我离开房间的时候，那家伙会来个《杜克兄弟》式的表演，跳过桥什么的。
Well, you know, he's picked up speed here. Look at this.
嗯，你知道，他加速了。看这个。
That is a good observation on your part. He has picked up some speed. He got up to about 45 to 50 miles an hour, the suspect, right now. He makes his turn.
你的观察很敏锐。他确实加速了。嫌疑人现在时速达到了45到50英里。他转弯了。
He's slowing down again, Larry.
他又慢下来了，拉里。
He is. He's slowing down. Begs the question, how much gas--
是的。他在减速。这就引出了一个问题，油箱里还有多少——
It wasn't, however, just the news team that was at a loss about how exactly to proceed. The cops who weren't chasing him were confused as well. Detective Brian Spencer of the Inglewood Police Department was on duty that night and remembers getting a strange call on his radio.
然而，不仅仅是新闻团队不知道该如何处理。没去追他的警察也感到困惑。英格尔伍德警察局的布莱恩·斯潘塞警探那天晚上正好当班，他记得电台里收到一个奇怪的呼叫。
Well, when I first heard about it, we were out on patrol in our marked police car. And California Highway Patrol or Los Angeles Police Department got on our radio frequency and said that they didn't want to follow a car anymore. And basically, they told all the police units to back out of it completely.
嗯，我第一次听说时，我们正在巡逻车里。加州公路巡警或洛杉矶警察局在我们的无线电频率上说，他们不想再跟着那辆车了。基本上，他们告诉所有警力完全撤出。
And you know, we were a little frustrated. Be like anything. Pick any profession, you know? You're supposed to do this, but then you don't do it. It doesn't feel like you fulfilled your job.
你知道，我们有点沮丧。就像任何职业一样，你知道吗？你本该做这件事，但却没做。感觉没尽到职责。
For me, it's pretty simple. They run, we chase.
对我来说，很简单。他们跑，我们就追。
So, like legions of cinematic counterparts before him, Detective Spencer decided to go with his gut and take the law into his own hands, even if it meant disobeying his superiors.
所以，就像他之前的无数电影前辈一样，斯潘塞警探决定遵从直觉，自行执法，哪怕这意味着违抗上级。
We just decided to follow him anyways.
我们还是决定跟着他。
Oh really? On your own?
噢，真的吗？就你们俩？
Yeah. Just the two of us. We found the car on Century Boulevard. That's a street in our city. And we happened to be down in that area, because we heard the pursuit was coming in our city. So we went down there snooping, and lo and behold, there it was.
对。就我们两个。我们在世纪大道发现了那辆车。那是我们市的一条街。我们正好在那一带，因为听说追逐正往我们市来。所以我们去那儿溜达，果不其然，它就在那儿。
Of course, now that they'd found the car, there was still the question of what to do next. I mean, how hard really could it be to catch this guy?
当然，既然他们找到了车，接下来该做什么还是个问题。我的意思是，抓这家伙到底能有多难？
He had stopped initially right-- there was a traffic light there, and he was stopped right there. And we wanted to just, you know, get out of car, and like open the door, and get him out of the car, but we knew we'd get in trouble if we did that.
他最初停在那儿——那儿有个红绿灯，他就停在那儿。我们本想直接下车，打开车门把他拉出来，但我们知道如果我们那样做会惹麻烦。
How many feet behind him were you when you were following him?
你跟着他的时候，离他多远？
Oh, I mean, we were right behind him. We were the car right behind him. Yeah. It was just like regular driving. He was doing like 35 on Century. He would stop at all the red lights. Just like we were on patrol, just driving around.
噢，我的意思是，我们就紧跟着他。我们就是紧跟在他后面的那辆车。对。就像正常开车。他在世纪大道上开35码。他会在所有红灯前停下。就像我们正在巡逻一样，只是在兜风。
Detective Spencer and his partner continued tailing the fugitive on their own for another quarter of an hour before they were called off for good by their boss, who, it turns out, was watching KCAL'S coverage of the chase back at the station.
斯潘塞警探和他的搭档自行跟踪了逃犯又一刻钟，才被他们的上司彻底叫停。原来，他们的上司当时正在电视台看KCAL对追逐的直播。
What happened was, when the car was on Century Boulevard, I had stuck my head out the window to yell at the guy to pull over. But it wasn't working. And the watch commander saw the car on the news, and that's when he told us to leave. So we did.
当时是这样，当车在世纪大道时，我把头伸出窗外冲他大喊让他靠边停车。但这没用。值班指挥官在新闻上看到了这辆车，这才叫我们撤离。于是我们就撤了。
We do know that he has stayed in the relatively general area around the airport, and--
我们知道他一直留在机场附近相对笼统的区域，并且——
That's at KCAL. The chase is still on, and the news team is no closer to answering the story's main questions. Who is this guy and why is he running?
那是KCAL的报道。追逐仍在继续，新闻团队离解答故事的核心问题并无进展。这家伙是谁？为什么要跑？
Ordinarily when you watch a chase on TV, the very least that you, the viewer can expect is that the people actually on the TV know slightly more than you do about the situation. It's usually a given. But in this case, the announcer didn't know the answers any more than anyone else did. So they just speculated like crazy.
通常当你在电视上看追逐时，作为观众，你至少能期待电视上的人比你知道得稍微多一点点。这通常是常识。但在这种情况下，主播知道的并不比任何人多。所以他们就开始疯狂猜测。
You just have to wonder, Patty, if the guy has to be aware of the fact that police have unmarked vehicles. And you have to be wondering if he's wondering if he's being pursued now by an unmarked police vehicle, being that SUV.
你得怀疑，帕蒂，这家伙是否意识到警察有无标识车辆。你得猜他是否在琢磨自己现在是不是被那辆SUV跟踪。
And while police may know who this individual is, the question still remains. Why did this person flee the scene of a relatively minor traffic accident, and then lead police on a chase that's now gone on for more than three hours? Do we have any idea if there are outstanding warrants, if this individual may be wanted for something else.
虽然警方可能知道此人是谁，但问题依然存在。为什么此人要逃离轻微交通事故现场，并引导警方进行了一场持续三个多小时的追逐？我们知道是否有未结案的逮捕令，他是否还涉及其他案件吗？
No. There was no warrants. Not a one. No. I hate to disappoint them, as a precedent-setting individual.
没有。没有逮捕令。一个都没有。不。我不想让他们失望，作为一个开先例的个体。
Ladies and gentlemen, I present to you the fugitive. He turned out to be a very affable and helpful guy, and he agreed to talk to me on the condition that I didn't use his name. So I'll just call him Dr. Richard Kimball. Dr. Kimball for short.
各位女士先生，向你们介绍这位逃犯。他实际上是个非常和蔼、乐于助人的家伙，他同意接受我的采访，条件是我不能用他的名字。所以我就叫他理查德·金布尔医生。简称金布尔医生。
On the night this all happened, Dr. Kimball had just finished up a big project for his consulting firm. He decided to celebrate by getting high. Because you see, aside from being a workaholic and Georgetown graduate, Dr. Kimball was also a crack addict.
事发当晚，金布尔医生刚为他的咨询公司完成了一个大项目。他决定吸毒庆祝一下。因为你看，除了是个工作狂和乔治城大学的毕业生，金布尔医生还是个可卡因瘾君子。
He'd gone to a hotel to smoke up that night so his family wouldn't see, and he was just leaving when he got into the fender bender. When he saw the flashing lights behind him, he ran.
他当晚去了一家酒店吸食，不想让家人看到，出来时就发生了剐蹭。看到身后的闪光灯，他就跑了。
By no means was there ever any delusion of thinking I was going to get away. No. That's the farthest thing from my mind. I knew that what I had done was wrong. They're on your tail right now. So I told myself, well, just drive a little bit more. Try to get your resolve together. Calm down.
我从没想过我能逃掉。不。那是我脑子里最不可能的事。我知道我做错了。他们就在我身后。所以我对自己说，嗯，再多开一会儿吧。试着稳住神。冷静点。
So the plan you had was to gain composure. Would you call it a plan?
所以你的计划是保持冷静。你会称之为计划吗？
A plan! But you know. It's unfortunate that-- and I can say this, because certainly, I'm black. Being stereotyped as a black man and having to step out of a vehicle looking all shoddy and sweaty, and hair all awry, and with that obvious-- man, the guy's on drugs-- it was like, wow. At least try to clean up your act a little bit.
计划！但你知道。不幸的是——我能这么说，因为我确实是黑人。作为一名黑人，被刻板印象对待，被迫走出车门时显得邋遢、满身大汗、头发乱糟糟，而且带着那种显而易见的——伙计，这人吸毒了——感觉就像，哇。至少尝试整理一下。
Talking to Dr. Kimball, he defies everyone's theory about why people run. He hadn't hurt anybody or stolen anything. He didn't think he could get away. And he definitely didn't want to be on TV.
与金布尔医生交谈，他推翻了每个人关于人们为什么逃跑的理论。他没伤害任何人，也没偷任何东西。他没想过能逃掉。他也绝对不想上电视。
There are people who study pursuits. Yes, there are actual people who do this. And they say that trying to figure out the reasons behind why people run, the cause behind the effect, is the wrong approach. What these experts have discovered is that there aren't any reasons behind why people run. There's just a type of person runs. They don't stop to weigh the consequences or to factor in all variables. They just run. They run because it doesn't occur to them not to.
有人专门研究追逐战。是的，真有人做这行。他们说，试图去找出人们为什么要跑的原因、因果关系，是错误的方法。这些专家发现，人们跑根本没有任何原因。就是有一种人会跑。他们不会停下来权衡后果或考量所有变量。他们只是跑。他们跑是因为脑子里没想过“不跑”。
Which is to say, Dr. Richard Kimball ran because he was born to run.
这就是说，理查德·金布尔医生跑，是因为他生来就会跑。
Oh, yeah, well, something you may not know, I've done this once before. This happened had happened three years before.
噢，对了，有件事你可能不知道，我以前做过一次。这是三年前发生的。
Really?
真的吗？
Yeah, yeah. Oh, yeah, really. The first time, I don't remember too many details about it. There was no hit and run. There was no accident or anything. I think it was a traffic infraction that just turned out to be a couple hour slow speed chase again.
是的，是的。噢，对，真的。第一次我不记得太多细节了。没有肇事逃逸。没有事故什么的。我想是个交通违规，结果又变成了一场几小时的低速追逐。
You know, I take great pride to think that I am a relatively decent, law-abiding citizen, OK? So even while under the influence, I'm very cognizant of stop signs, turn signals.
你知道，我很自豪能认为自己是一个相对体面、守法的公民，好吗？所以即使在吸毒状态下，我也非常注意停车标志和转向灯。
Dr. Richard Kimball tells me that driving around, he had no idea he was on the news. He also tells me that he didn't know the cops had pulled out.
理查德·金布尔医生告诉我，开车时，他根本不知道自己上了新闻。他还告诉我，他不知道警察撤走了。
So I run by him some of the questions that the newscasters had. I asked him if the cops were in contact with his family. He tells me no. I asked him if he thought that SUV driving behind him was an undercover policeman. He tells me no. I asked him if he planned on driving home. He tells me he wasn't thinking about it that clearly.
所以我向他抛出了一些新闻主播提出的问题。我问他警察是否联系了他的家人。他告诉我没有。我问他是否认为那辆在他后面开的SUV是便衣警察。他告诉我没有。我问他是否打算开车回家。他告诉我不记得当时想得那么清楚。
Did you have any particular pattern of where you were driving or a particular area that you were circling?
你有没有特定的驾驶路线或绕行的特定区域？
Oh, no. Strictly random. Like a leaf in a windstorm.
噢，没有。完全随机。像暴风雨中的一片落叶。
Does your car get good gas mileage?
你的车油耗高吗？
I think it's probably like 24, 25 miles to a gallon.
我想大概是每加仑24、25英里吧。
Would you call it a fuel-efficient car?
你会称它为省油的车吗？
I would, I would.
我会，我会。
Did you have a cell phone in the car with you?
车里有手机吗？
I did.
有。
Did you use it to call anyone?
你用它给别人打过电话吗？
Nope. Nor did I keep the radio turned on, either. Just had a CD playing, if I recall correctly.
没。收音机也没开。如果我没记错，就在放CD。
What was it?
是什么歌？
Boston. Yeah. Their first album, More Than A Feeling . You laugh, but I mean, that's my favorite group.
波士顿乐队。是的。他们的第一张专辑，《不仅仅是一种感觉》。你笑，但我意思是，那是我的最爱。
Can I just tell you that learning these answers was ridiculously satisfying? It's hard to put into words exactly, but it felt sort of like scratching an itch, while simultaneously solving a crossword puzzle, at the precise instant that, after racking your brains for it for two solid years, the name of your best friend from kindergarten suddenly pops into your head. It felt like that, only better.
我能告诉你吗？得到这些答案真是无比满足。很难用言语确切表达，感觉就像挠到了痒处，同时又解开了一个填字游戏，在你绞尽脑汁想了整整两年后，幼儿园好友的名字突然跳进你的脑海。感觉就像那样，甚至更好。
Incredibly, there was one piece of KCAL speculation that came true. It was something they latched onto early on and that they kept coming back to over and over again, throughout the four hours, debating about when it would happen. Somehow they knew that this chase wasn't over, would never be over, until the fugitive ran out of gas.
令人难以置信的是，KCAL的一项猜测成真了。这是他们很早就抓住并不停回到这一点的一点，整整四个小时里，一直在争论什么时候会发生。他们不知怎的知道这场追逐还没完，永远不会完，直到逃犯耗光汽油。
I think the low fuel indicator light came on. If I recall correctly, the red light came on, and I'm sitting there going, well, maybe two gallons, three gallons at the most. What are you going to do? Are you going to run out on the freeway, or are you going to pull over and give up?
我想低油量指示灯亮了。如果我没记错，红灯亮了，我坐在那儿想，嗯，可能还剩两加仑，顶多三加仑。你要怎么做？你是要在那儿耗光汽油，还是靠边停车投降？
So right now, the suspect is pulling over now, here in Inglewood. We don't know if he's out of gas, but he has completely pulled over and blacked out. And stand by one second. We'll see what's going to happen here.
所以现在，嫌疑人正在靠边停车，就在英格尔伍德。我们不知道他是不是没油了，但他已经完全靠边并熄火了。请稍等一秒。我们要看看会发生什么。
We'd driven away, and went somewhere and parked, and we're talking about it, a partner and I.
我们开车走开了，找了个地方停下，我和搭档在讨论这事。
Again, Detective Spencer. After getting called off the chase, he and his partner pulled over and parked in a nearby area. They kept listening for any word of what was going on, but the radio was silent. They had no idea that the fugitive had pulled over, and were in fact still feeling frustrated that they'd been called off.
又是斯潘塞警探。在被叫停追逐后，他和搭档靠边停在附近区域。他们一直在听还有什么消息，但电台一片死寂。他们不知道逃犯已经停下了，实际上仍在为自己被叫停而感到沮丧。
We were just taking a breath, you know?
我们当时只是在喘口气，你知道吗？
Venting.
在发泄。
Yeah, exactly. We're just like, we couldn't believe that after four hours, he was just going to get away.
对，没错。我们就是觉得，不敢相信四个小时后，他竟然就这样逃掉了。
No ground units yet, as far as we can see. Don't see any movement of any doors at this particular point, and we do know that law enforcement agencies did back off, and they will probably be sending in ground units momentarily.
目前还没看到地面部队。目前为止还没看到任何车门有动静，我们确实知道执法部门撤了，他们可能很快会派地面部队过去。
No helicopter lights on the suspect. We can see a vehicle approaching-- I guess, no, he's just making a turn. But--
直升机灯光没照着嫌疑人。我们看到有车辆靠近——我想，不，他只是在转弯。但是——
I distinctly remember sitting there in the car. Certainly there was no sirens, no lights. And then, I'll never forget. There was a couple of young black women were coming from a gas station on the corner. They were walking across the street. And one of them yelled out, "There the fool is!"
我清楚地记得坐在车里。肯定没有警笛，没有灯光。然后，我永远不会忘记。有几个年轻黑人女性从街角的加油站出来。她们正走过马路。其中一个大喊：“那傻瓜就在那儿！”
And was that when it really registered that this might be on TV?
那就是你真正意识到这可能在电视上播出的时候吗？
Yeah, yeah, for sure.
对，对，肯定的。
Meanwhile, while sitting in his parked squad car, Detective Spencer received a phone call.
同时，坐在巡逻车里的斯潘塞警探接到了一个电话。
My wife called me on my cell phone and said, "You know this car that everyone was chasing is in your city? It stopped at like Ash and Manchester. And he's just sitting there." And I said, "Really? The car's where?"
我妻子打我手机说：“你知道大家都在追的那辆车就在你们市吗？它停在阿什和曼彻斯特路口那儿。他就坐在那儿。”我说：“真的吗？那车在哪儿？”
She'd been watching the chase on TV?
她在电视上看追逐？
Yeah. She was flipping back and forth between that and a Dave Matthews interview. And then she said, "You know, you guys look really dumb right now. There's a guy sitting in your city, and the helicopters are up, and it's all over the news, and they're saying that Inglewood police isn't doing anything. And the guy in a helicopter's saying that normally I tell them not to run from the police, because you'll never get away, but this guy seems like he's going to." And she said, "You know, you might want to go over there." And you can see our car just come down the street.
对。她在那个节目和一个戴夫·马修斯的采访之间换来换去。然后她说：“你知道吗，你们现在看起来真的很蠢。有个家伙坐在你们市，直升机在上头转，新闻里到处都在报，他们还在说英格尔伍德警察什么都没做。直升机里的人还在说，通常我会告诉人们别从警察手里逃走，因为你绝对跑不掉，但这家伙好像真要跑掉了。”她说：“你知道吗，你可能想过去看看。”你可以看到我们的车正开下街道。
--this driver presents any kind of an immediate threat--
——这个司机是否存在任何即时威胁——
I see an LAPD officer right there. Through that intersection there.
我看到一名洛杉矶警察在那儿。穿过那个十字路口。
There's one right behind him, too.
他后面也有一个。
OK. There they are, right behind him now. So officers just pulled in right now. They have their guns drawn. The suspect is now getting out. The suspect appears to be an older man, heavy-set, and he's making his way back. No resistance whatsoever. Those are Inglewood PD officers. And now the suspect is in custody. He's in the custody of the Inglewood PD.
好。他们在那儿，现在就在他后面。所以警察现在刚过去。他们拔出了枪。嫌疑人现在正出来。嫌疑人看起来是个老人，身形魁梧，他正在往回走。完全没有抵抗。那是英格尔伍德警察局的警察。现在嫌疑人被拘留了。他被英格尔伍德警局拘留了。
Throughout all of this, the only person who didn't doubt that he the fugitive would get caught was the fugitive. And in the end, perhaps that's why he got caught. His faith in his inevitable capture turned out to be self-fulfilling. Here's Detective Spencer.
自始至终，唯一不怀疑逃犯会被抓的人就是逃犯本人。最后，或许这就是他被抓的原因。他对必将被捕的信念，最终变成了自我实现的预言。这是斯潘塞警探。
I mean, if he would have ran or did something, you know, I believe that news helicopters up there, and they don't have like to the infrareds and the spotlights and all that thing. And so I mean, technically, he probably could have got away if he would have ran, but he didn't. He just sat there.
我是说，如果他跑了或者做了什么，你知道，我相信头顶上的那些新闻直升机，他们没有那种红外线和探照灯什么的。所以技术上说，如果他跑的话他大概能逃掉，但他没跑。他只是坐在那儿。
I don't think I ever thought that. And it certainly isn't, it is not my MO to have gotten out of the car and added yet another segment to the chase by me running over fences and through backyards.
我不认为我曾那样想过。而且，下车再跑过栅栏、穿过后院，再为追逐增加一段戏份，绝对不是我的行事风格。
So you weren't surprised when the cops showed up.
所以警察出现时你并不惊讶。
Well, no, no. Because that's what happens in those sorts of situations. No, I wasn't surprised. Of course not.
嗯，不，不。因为那种情况下就是会发生这种事。不，我不惊讶。当然不。
[INAUDIBLE] pursuit that we've never really seen anybody get away here, and this would have been the first one.
[听不清]追逐，我们从未见过有人能逃掉，而这本可能是第一个。
The news team gives its closing comments. And consistent with the rest of the evening, they seem to apply to a whole different case altogether.
新闻团队给出了结语。和那天晚上的表现一致，他们似乎是在谈论一个完全不同的案件。
And I have to point out that out after this entire pursuit here, four hours long, nobody got hurt during this pursuit, and that is the best news, Bob.
我得指出，经过这整个持续四小时的追逐，没有人受伤，这是最好的消息，鲍勃。
OK. The executive producer says we have to take a break, Larry. OK?
好。执行制作人说我们得进广告了，拉里。好吗？
Sounds good to me.
听起来不错。
All right. We'll be right back.
好的。我们马上回来。
Here's what happened next. Dr. Richard Kimball was arrested and taken to trial. He was given two years for felony evasion and possession of cocaine, although he only had to serve a year. Ironically, the initial hit and run charge that started it all was dropped completely due to a lack of evidence. If he hadn't run in the first place, he probably wouldn't have gone to jail.
接下来发生了什么。理查德·金布尔医生被捕并接受审判。他因重罪逃避和持有可卡因被判两年，尽管只服刑了一年。讽刺的是，最初导致这一切的肇事逃逸指控，因为缺乏证据完全被驳回了。如果他当初没跑，他可能根本就不会坐牢。
For a short while, on the night of August 31, 2001, this chase was KCAL's biggest story. A possibly dangerous fugitive who obeyed all traffic lives had managed to elude LA's police force for four hours for reasons nobody could fathom. And now that he'd been apprehended, we would finally learn the story behind it all.
在2001年8月31日晚上的短时间内，这场追逐是KCAL最大的新闻。一个遵守所有交通法规、可能危险的逃犯，竟然因为无人能解的原因，成功从洛杉矶警队手下逃脱了四个小时。现在他被捕了，我们终于能了解背后的故事了。
But immediately after the capture of Dr. Richard Kimball, KCAL returned to its regular programming. There was no follow up the next day or the next week. In fact, there was never any. My conversation with Dr. Richard Kimball turned out to be an exclusive. In the two years since the case, no one has ever contacted him from the press. When I called him, it was the first time he'd learned that he'd been the star of that night's news.
但在理查德·金布尔医生被捕后，KCAL立刻恢复了正常节目。第二天或下周没有任何后续报道。事实上，从来都没有。我和理查德·金布尔医生的谈话成了独家报道。在此案之后的两年里，没有任何媒体联系过他。当我给他打电话时，那是他第一次知道自己曾是那天晚上新闻的主角。
Most everyone remembers where they were during the OJ chase, because it was one of those times when you could tell beyond the shadow of a doubt that you were expecting history in the making. But if all history starts off as news, not all news becomes history. No one remembers where they were for this case. Except, of course, the man wasn't being chased, the man he wasn't chasing, and the diehard fan hovering in the air above.
大多数人都记得O.J.追逐时他们在哪里，因为那是你可以毫不怀疑地断定你正在经历历史时刻的时候。但如果所有历史都始于新闻，并非所有新闻都会成为历史。没人记得这起案子时他们在哪里。除了，当然，那个没被追的男人，那个没追他的警察，还有盘旋在头顶上空的死忠粉丝。
Starlee Kine.
斯塔莉·基恩。
Coming up-- a film that makes you cry every four minutes, or me cry every four minutes, and a seafood buffet on the shores of Alabama. That's all in a minute from Chicago Public Radio and Public Radio International when our program continues.
接下来——一部让你每四分钟就哭一次的电影，或者让我每四分钟就哭一次的电影，还有阿拉巴马海岸的海鲜自助。就在一分钟后，来自芝加哥公共广播和国际公共广播，节目继续。
It's This American Life. I'm David Rakoff, sitting in for Ira Glass.
这是《美国生活》。我是大卫·拉科夫，代班伊拉·格拉斯。
Each week we choose a theme, a subject, a question, and invite a variety of writers, reporters, and performers to take a whack at it. Today's program-- Like It Or Not. Stories about inevitability and the actions we take or don't.
每周我们选一个主题、一个议题、一个问题，邀请各种作家、记者和表演者来探讨。今天的节目——《无论喜不喜欢》。关于不可避免性的故事，以及我们所做或未做的决定。
We've arrived at act two of our program. Don't Just Stand There.
我们进入节目的第二幕。《别只是站在那儿》。
When you get to know someone-- really know them-- you can almost predict their behavior. What they might say or do in a given situation, how they'll react to a movie or a book. It's comforting, this intimacy. It reduces the chance for unpleasant surprises.
当你了解某人——真正了解他们——你几乎能预见他们的行为。在特定情况下他们会说什么、做什么，对电影或书有什么反应。这种亲密感令人欣慰。它减少了出现不愉快惊喜的机会。
But what about when something comes up that requires someone to transcend his character? When what is most needed is for those around you to behave in no way like themselves? Sheila Peabody has this story about just such a moment.
但是，当出现需要某人超越自身性格的情况时呢？当最需要的是周围的人表现得完全不像他们自己的时候呢？希拉·皮博迪带来了关于这样一个时刻的故事。
My father has always been a mild man, and all my friends whose fathers were mean or domineering always told me how lucky I was to have him. He's gentle, kind, and introverted. His great loves have always been the once-removed kind-- architecture, opera, multivolume Jefferson biographies.
我父亲一直是个温和的人，所有那些父亲严厉或专横的朋友总是告诉我，有他这样的父亲是多么幸运。他温和、善良、内向。他毕生的最爱一直都是那种隔了一层的兴趣——建筑、歌剧、多卷本的杰斐逊传记。
But he's what psychologists would call, well, passive. When he helps you carry the groceries into the house, he'll stand next to an empty kitchen counter and wait for you to tell him to put them down. Most of the time, this is not a big deal. You say, "Right there, on the counter," and he puts them down. He was the kind of dad who could read a newspaper completely unflustered as you had a temper tantrum. The detachment wasn't a parenting strategy. He just wasn't so keen on being an authority figure.
但他属于心理学家所说的那种——嗯，被动。当他帮你把杂货搬进屋时，他会站在空的厨房台面边，等着你告诉他把东西放下。大多数时候，这没什么大不了。你说：“就放那儿，台面上，”他就放下了。他是那种在你发脾气时能心平气和看报纸的父亲。这种疏离感并非育儿策略。他只是不太热衷于成为一个权威人物。
Faced with my dad's passivity, my mother used to say to me, "When I get old, I'd rather be in a state nursing home than have your father take care of me." That was her worst fear, I think. What he'd do, or more to the point, what he wouldn't do if she was totally helpless and needed him.
面对父亲的被动，母亲过去常对我说：“我老了以后，宁愿住在州立疗养院，也不愿让你父亲照顾我。”我想那是她最担心的事情。如果她完全无助、需要他时，他会做什么——或者更准确地说，他不会做什么。
Then last year it happened. My mom was at home alone with my dad and she started feeling breathless, and he waited to call 911. He waited for her to ask him to do it.
去年这件事发生了。我妈和我爸独自在家，她开始感到呼吸困难，而他等着打911。他在等她开口让他打。
It was nine in the morning on a sunny July day. They'd been setting up in armchairs at the kitchen table, dozing on and off since 3 AM. She was afraid of lying down, afraid of really falling asleep, because of what had happened a couple of days before. She had woken up feeling breathless and said, "Honey, call 911. I can't breathe."
那天是七月一个阳光明媚的日子，早上九点。从凌晨三点起，他们就一直坐在厨房桌边的扶手椅上，断断续续地打瞌睡。她害怕躺下，害怕真的睡着，因为前几天发生的事情。她曾醒来感到呼吸困难，说：“亲爱的，打911。我喘不过气。”
He did, and the ambulance rushed her to the hospital. They put her on medication, and kept her for 24 hours for tests, and then sent her home, telling her it wasn't a heart attack, just an episode, because she'd skipped her medication for three days for a heart arrhythmia she'd managed for decades without a hitch.
他打了，救护车送她去了医院。医生给她开了药，留院观察了24小时进行检查，然后让她回家，说这不是心脏病发作，只是个小发作，因为她为了治疗一种几十年来一直平安无事的心律失常，竟然停药了三天。
I think she left the hospital feeling she might have overreacted. They certainly didn't tell her, "If it happens again, call 911 immediately." They didn't say, "If you don't feel better, come right in."
我想她离开医院时觉得可能反应过度了。他们肯定没告诉她：“如果再发生这种情况，立即打911。”他们没说：“如果不舒服，立刻过来。”
So there they were, sitting in the kitchen armchairs, and the phone rang. We don't know who called. My dad assumes it was a telemarketer. Later when he told me he would shake his head bitterly, as if the telemarketer really should have known better.
于是，他们当时就坐在厨房的扶手椅上，电话响了。我们不知道是谁打的。我爸认为是推销电话。后来他告诉我时，会痛苦地摇头，好像那个推销员真的应该懂事点才对。
My mother jumped up to answer it. It didn't take much to trigger her heart racing. She said hello, and then put the phone down. "I wish I hadn't done that," she said. suddenly breathless. "Should I call 911?" my father asked. "Oh, not that again," my mother said. So my father waited. My mother hated doctors, and the last thing he wanted was to incur her wrath by inviting those arrogant young men to manhandle and advise her all over again.
我母亲跳起来去接。触发她心跳加速并不需要太多。她说了声你好，然后放下了电话。“我真希望没接那个电话，”她突然气喘吁吁地说。“要打911吗？”我父亲问。“噢，别再提那个了，”我母亲说。于是我父亲等着。我母亲讨厌医生，他最不想做的就是招惹那些傲慢的年轻人来乱动她、给她提建议。
She took an aspirin. My father helped her take her shirt off, because she said she was hot. Gradually the attack escalated. She panted, squealed, yelped. She held her arms out in a stiff imitation of a Frankenstein shudder. I know these things because my father offered muted renditions of them the first few days after she died for whoever would watch.
她吃了阿司匹林。我父亲帮她脱掉衬衫，因为她说热。渐渐地，病症升级了。她喘气、尖叫、哀鸣。她伸出双臂，僵硬地模仿着弗兰肯斯坦的颤抖。我知道这些细节，因为在我母亲去世后的头几天，我父亲给任何愿意观看的人表演了这些细节。
Then she passed out. My father would act this out as well, dropping his head back in the chair where she died, his mouth open, arms slack. "She was just gone," he'd say, shaking his head. It was then, he said, after she passed out, that he called 911.
然后她晕过去了。我父亲也会表演这个，把头后仰在椅子上，就像她去世时那样，嘴巴张开，双臂无力。“她就这样走了，”他摇着头说。他说，就在她晕过去之后，他才打了911。
"How long did this take?" I always ask, wanting to hear something different. "10, 15 minutes. I don't know." "That's an eternity," I say. My dad nods, agreeable. "So you waited until she passed out to call 911?" I really want to say "died," but don't have the heart. "I think so. I don't remember," my dad answers.
“这花了多久？”我总是问，希望能听到不一样的答案。“10、15分钟吧。我不记得了。”“那是一段永恒，”我说。我父亲点头同意。“所以你等到她晕过去才打911？”我真的很想说“死了”，但没忍心。“我想是吧。我不记得了，”我父亲回答。
The paramedics finally arrived. They put a tube down her throat, did CPR, but she didn't come back. In his own car, my dad had to follow my mom's ambulance to the hospital for the disposition of her body.
医护人员终于赶到了。他们给她的喉咙插了管，做了心肺复苏，但她没醒过来。我父亲只好开着自己的车，跟着救护车去医院处理她的遗体。
When it had sunk in that they weren't reviving her, he called the family from hospital. He left a message at work on my voicemail. He said, "I have some very sad news. Your mother passed away this morning. I'm here at the hospital and I'm all alone, and it's just awful, awful." He hung up.
当他意识到他们无法救活她时，他在医院给家里打了电话。他在我工作的语音信箱里留了言。他说：“我有个非常悲伤的消息。你母亲今天早上过世了。我现在在医院，我一个人，真的太可怕了，太可怕了。”然后他挂了。
In the days just after my mother died, my father talked guiltily about not responding quickly enough, about not feeling he had the strength to lay her on the ground as the 911 operator instructed him to do. I told him, no, don't blame yourself. How could you have known?
母亲刚去世的那几天，父亲内疚地谈起自己没有及时反应，谈起觉得自己没力气按照911接线员的指导把她平放在地上。我说，不，别怪自己。你怎么可能知道呢？
But secretly I had to wonder. Had my father done with my mother's life what he'd always done when he noticed there was no butter at the dinner table? He'd ask, "Where's the butter?" then place his hands slowly on the table, pretending to raise himself up in a supreme effort, waiting to see if anyone else would leap into action.
但私底下我不禁怀疑。我父亲是否对他母亲的生活做了他一直做的事——当他发现餐桌上没有黄油时？他会问：“黄油在哪儿？”然后慢慢地把手放在桌子上，假装费力地支撑起自己，等着看是否有人会跃跃欲试。
My dad wasn't negligent, exactly. All she had to do was ask, of course. But it's hard not to see this moment-- her dying, him waiting to be asked to call 911-- as the inevitable ending to a 50 year relationship that simply never changed.
我爸并不是故意疏忽。当然，她只要开口就行。但很难不把这一刻——她快死了，他等着被要求打911——看作是一段50年关系中不可避免的结局，这种关系从未改变。
She was always looking to him to provide the final word, and he was looking to her for the same. The problem was, they wanted completely different final words. She wanted him to say, "Let's talk about the state of our marriage, let's plan a party, let's worry about one of our children and devise a way to make a million dollars. How about it?" And he wanted her to say, "The spatula is in the second drawer to the left. But don't bother, sweetheart. I've already cooked your one egg sunny-side up. Yolks broke, whole-wheat toast buttered, coffee very hot, not too strong, with half-and-half, not milk."
她总是期待他提供最终的决定，而他也在期待她做同样的事。问题是，他们想要的是完全不同的决定。她想让他说：“咱们谈谈婚姻状况，咱们计划个派对，咱们为孩子担心，想个办法赚一百万。怎么样？”而他想让她说：“铲子在左边第二个抽屉里。但别忙了，亲爱的。我已经煎好了你的单面荷包蛋。蛋黄没破，全麦吐司抹了黄油，咖啡很烫，不是很浓，加了半对半奶油，没加牛奶。”
No matter what she threw at the relationship-- philosophy, feminism, therapy, Prozac, love, and patience, and rage-- she could never get him to play her way. "What do you want me to do?" he'd say, after she'd been lecturing him about one thing or another, an unreadable smile just visible behind his eyes. "Just tell me what to say, and I'll say it."
无论她对这段关系投入什么——哲学、女权主义、心理疗法、百忧解、爱、耐心和愤怒——她都无法让他按她的方式来。“你到底想让我做什么？”他会说，在她讲完一通道理后，眼里闪烁着一种难以读懂的微笑。“你只要告诉我该说什么，我就说。”
In the end, maybe I wasn't any better than my dad. I acted the same way I'd always acted. I pretended things would be fine. The day before my mom died, I called her from work and asked her how she was. "Oh, I've been better," she said cheerfully, explaining she'd just gotten back from the hospital and was feeling breathless. "The cardiologist really acted strangely," she added. "I'll tell you all about it when we have time."
最后，或许我并不比我爸强。我的行为和我一贯的表现一样。我假装一切都会好起来。我妈去世的前一天，我从单位给她打电话问她怎么样。“噢，我好多了，”她愉快地说，解释说刚从医院回来，感觉喘不上气。“心脏科医生表现得很奇怪，”她补充道。“等我们有空时，我会把一切告诉你。”
The next morning I awoke feeling uneasy, and told my husband so. Still, our life was crazy, and I didn't have room for another crisis, so I decided it just couldn't happen.
第二天早上醒来，我感到不安，并告诉了我丈夫。尽管如此，我们的生活很疯狂，我没有余力处理另一场危机，所以我决定这不可能发生。
Now looking at all or behavior, I think, how could we all have been so stupid? Why weren't we all acting like life didn't sometimes require us to just act a little differently? Why didn't I drop everything to take care of her? Why didn't he notice she was dying in that moment, that she couldn't ask for help?
现在回顾我们的行为，我想，我们怎么会这么蠢？为什么我们都没有表现得好像生活有时要求我们表现得稍微不同一点？为什么我没放下一切去照顾她？为什么他在那一刻没注意到她正在死去，她无法开口求救？
After my mother died, a friend who had suddenly lost her father wrote me. "The only thing we can learn from her parents," she said, "is to resolve not to make the same mistakes." I keep on trying to figure out what I'm supposed to learn from this. If my mother died from her worst fear, what must I do to avoid mine?
母亲去世后，一位突然失去父亲的朋友给我写信。“我们能从她父母身上学到的唯一一件事，”她说，“就是下定决心不要重蹈覆辙。”我一直试图弄清楚我该从中汲取什么。如果我母亲死于她最大的恐惧，为了避免我的恐惧，我该做什么？
My worst fear used to be my mother's death. Now it's that I have a blind spot like she had about something in my life I'm not able to transform, no matter how hard I try. How do you begin to see your own blind spot?
我最大的恐惧曾经是我母亲的死。现在是，在我的生活中，我像她一样有一个盲点，无论我如何努力都无法改变。你该如何开始发现自己的盲点？
Weird little things help. Like it helps to remember a conversation my brother said he had once with my father, when his world, like some mountain cracking open for the Pied Piper, became visible for the briefest moment. My dad was staring into space and my brother asked him, "Dad, what are you thinking about right now?" "The hippopotamus," answered my father, apropos of nothing. "What's the hippopotamus doing?" my brother asked him. "Oh," my father said, "he's going back to the forest."
一些奇怪的小事会有所帮助。比如记住我哥哥说他曾经和我父亲的一次谈话，当时他的世界，就像山峦裂开迎接吹笛人一样，在极短的一瞬变得可见。我爸当时在发呆，我哥哥问他：“爸，你现在在想什么？”“河马，”我父亲答道，没头没脑的。“河马在干什么？”我哥哥问他。“噢，”我父亲说，“它在回森林的路上。”
Sheila Peabody from the San Francisco Bay Area.
希拉·皮博迪，来自旧金山湾区。
Act Three. Hello, Baby.
第三幕，《你好，宝贝》。
A lot of life's inevitability is hazy. It will happen sometime, but you're not sure when. But with pregnancy, it's on an invariable schedule-- 40 weeks. At 36 weeks, producer Wendy Dorr was experiencing an essential contradiction in pregnancy, which is, the thing that she was most looking forward to was also the thing that scared the hell out of her.
人生中很多不可避免的事情都很模糊。它会在某个时候发生，但你不知道是什么时候。但怀孕是有固定周期的——40周。在36周时，制作人温迪·多尔经历了一种怀孕中本质的矛盾，那就是，她最期待的事情，也是最让她害怕的事情。
She explained the basic fear to me, which, to put it bluntly, was--
她向我解释了这种基本的恐惧，直白地说就是——
To push this giant, you know, melon out of your vagina.
把这个巨大的，你知道，甜瓜从你的阴道里推出来。
Well, how high is your level of fear from a one to ten?
好吧，你的恐惧水平从一到十是多少？
Probably nine. Probably a nine. Part of it is this feeling of, there's nothing I can do. Like, I have no choice now. What else am I going to do? Like, find a substitute? Or quit? Or just decide I don't want to do it anymore? There's one way out.
大概九。可能是九。其中一部分是这种感觉，我什么也做不了。就像，我现在别无选择。我还能做什么？找个替代品？还是放弃？或者直接决定不想做了？只有一条出路。
She's right. There really is only one way out. And the basic belief is that the better you prepare, the better you'll be able to deal with it. There are books about what to expect, videos you can watch, classes you can take. But does it actually help to prepare for something like this?
她说得对。确实只有一条出路。基本的信念是，你准备得越好，你就越能应付。有关于期待的书，你可以看的视频，你可以上的课程。但为这样的事情做准备真的有帮助吗？
My name is Wendy, and my due date's the 26th.
我叫温迪，预产期是26号。
Wendy takes me to her Lamaze class to see. We're in the Elizabeth Bing Center for Parents, a ground floor apartment in a building on the Upper West Side. Six women, three husbands, myself, and Fritzi, the teacher, sit on chairs in a circle in the main room.
温迪带我去她的拉玛泽课程看看。我们在伊丽莎白·宾父母中心，上西区一栋建筑的一楼公寓。六位女性、三位丈夫、我本人，以及老师弗里齐，围坐在主屋的椅子上。
The highlight of today's class is going to be a film of childbirth.
今天课程的重头戏是一部关于分娩的电影。
The hours that precede your baby's birth may provide physical and emotional challenges that are hard to anticipate. But taking time to prepare will give you confidence. Also, it will reassure you that although bringing your child into the world takes work, it is work with a very special reward.
宝宝出生前的几个小时可能会带来难以预料的身体和情感挑战。但花时间做准备会给你自信。此外，它会让你放心，虽然把孩子带到这个世界上需要努力，但这是一项有着非常特殊回报的工作。
We did it, he's here. Hello, baby.
我们做到了，他来了。你好，宝贝。
Hello, baby. That's the name of the movie. The title card comes up at that moment.
你好，宝贝。这就是那部电影的名字。标题字幕在那一刻浮现。
At 20 minutes or so, it's the highlights of childbirth. It's not some 18-hour Andy Warhol verite epic. It looks to be from the early '80s.  It's shot on film. It's three couples, each going through the labor process, and ending, of course, with the vaginal birth of a healthy baby.
大约20分钟左右，是分娩的精华片段。它不是那种18小时的安迪·沃霍尔式的纪实史诗。看起来像是80年代初的。用胶片拍摄。是三对夫妇，每对都在经历分娩过程，当然，结局是健康宝宝的阴道分娩。
The same thing happened all three times. Which is, you begin by focusing on how dated things look, how fried their hair seems. But that recedes as you go along.
三次的结果都一样。那就是，你开始时会关注事物看起来有多过时，他们的发型看起来有多炸。但随着进度，这种关注会退去。
It's incredibly intense to watch a baby being born. You get sucked into the undeniable drama of it all, even though you know how it's going to end.
观看宝宝出生是非常强烈的体验。你会陷入其中不可否认的戏剧性，尽管你知道结局会是什么。
It was so incredible looking in the mirror when his head was born. Then, all of a sudden, Kyle Junior was in my arms.
当他出生时，看着镜子里的场景真是太不可思议了。然后，突然间，小凯尔就在我怀里了。
Oh my God!
噢，天哪！
[BABY CRYING]
[婴儿啼哭]
At this point, I'm crying. I cried three times. Every time a baby was born. But Wendy cried, too. Seeing it firsthand made it seem significantly less scary to me. Then again, I'm not having a baby.
这时，我在哭。我哭了三次。每次宝宝出生时都哭。但温迪也哭了。亲眼见到它让我觉得它没那么可怕了。话又说回来，又不是我在生孩子。
It was-- I guess I felt the same. It seemed really painful and out-of-control to see it.
那是——我想感觉是一样的。看到这一幕，觉得真的很痛苦，且失去控制。
She's still glad she saw the movie. She's glad she took the prenatal course. It hasn't made the inevitability that much less scary. But as we talk, it emerges that preparation might not even be the real goal of these classes.
她还是很高兴看了电影。她很高兴上了产前课程。它并没有让那种不可避免性变得没那么可怕。但当我们交谈时，发现准备工作甚至可能不是这些课程真正的目标。
What the classes, is just-- it's like having something to do with your hands. It's just busywork to get you through the weeks of waiting. And it's doing that. It's keeping me preoccupied.
这些课程是什么呢，只是——就像手里得有点什么事做。这只是打发等待周期的忙碌工作。确实起作用了。它让我全神贯注。
But then why not just pick up a hobby? Why not learn lacemaking or something? What is it specifically about confronting the details?
但为什么不随便学点爱好？为什么不学做花边什么的？直面细节到底有什么特殊的意义？
Lacemaking? I would feel a little irresponsible. Because even though I realize that I'm going to have pretty much no control over what happens when I actually do go into labor, there's this sense that the more I learn about it, the more I can feel like I'm in control, even though I know that I won't be.
做花边？我会觉得有点不负责任。因为虽然我意识到我真正进入分娩时基本无法控制发生的一切，但有种感觉是，我了解得越多，就越能感觉我在掌控中，尽管我知道我并不能。
Producer Wendy Dorr. Four weeks after that interview, she gave birth to a daughter, Lucy.
制作人温迪·多尔。那次采访四周后，她生下了一个女儿，露西。
Act Four. On the Eighth Day, God Created Tartar Sauce.
第四幕，《第八天，上帝创造了塔塔酱》。
We have to begin this story with a little bit of science. In the deeper parts of Mobile Bay on the Gulf of Mexico, in Alabama, there is a pocket of water that's very low in oxygen. Basically, it's a dead zone. No fish live there. But under certain conditions, and usually during the middle of the night, that pocket of water can move, driving all sorts of fish-- crabs, shrimp, flounder, eels, stingrays, whatnot-- out of its way. The fish are pushed all the way to the shoreline and surge up on to the beach. They're alive, but kind of dazed, so they're easy to collect. It's a totally free, all-you-can-eat seafood buffet. This is called a jubilee.
我们必须以一点科学知识开始这个故事。在阿拉巴马州墨西哥湾的莫比尔湾深处，有一块含氧量极低的区域。基本上，那是个死区。没有鱼活得下来。但在特定条件下，通常在半夜，那团水会移动，将各种鱼类——螃蟹、虾、比目鱼、鳗鱼、黄貂鱼等等——赶出原位。鱼群被一直推到岸边，涌上沙滩。它们活着，但有些头昏脑胀，所以很容易收集。这是一个完全免费的“畅吃”海鲜自助。这被称为“庆典”。
The jubilee has a season, just like a hurricane-- but a really nice hurricane. It happens in late summer, sometimes more than once. No one seems to know exactly when or how often, but it's pretty much guaranteed as an annual event. Curtis Sittenfeld tells more.
庆典有季节，就像飓风一样——但这是种非常美好的飓风。它发生在夏末，有时不止一次。没人确切知道它何时发生或频率如何，但它几乎被保证是年度盛事。柯蒂斯·西滕费尔德讲述了更多。
As people in Mobile Bay explain it, there's nothing quite like a jubilee. They're strange and exciting, and they're really, really fun.
正如莫比尔湾的人所解释的那样，没有什么能比得上庆典。它们既奇怪又令人兴奋，而且真的、真的很有趣。
Have you ever seen so many fish? There's a big flounder coming in. See him out there? Let him come in a little bit.
你见过这么多鱼吗？那是条大比目鱼进来了。看那边那条？让它进来一点。
This is a videotape of a jubilee shot in 1991 by a man named Bird Zundel. It's dark out, so as people walk around in a shallow water near the shore, they're shining really bright lights. In the water, there's basically this chaos of fish. Eels slithering by, and flounder carpeting the sand, and catfish swimming in huge schools, and crabs moving sideways or climbing up on a jetty. I'm not sure how else to say it except that the water is crowded, like Penn Station at rush hour.
这是一盘1991年由伯德·尊德尔拍摄的关于庆典的录像带。外面天很黑，所以人们在岸边的浅水中走动时，打着非常亮的灯。水里基本上是一片鱼的混乱。鳗鱼游过，比目鱼铺满了沙子，鲶鱼成群结队地游动，螃蟹横着走或爬上防波堤。我不知道怎么形容，除了说水里很拥挤，就像高峰时刻的宾州车站。
That is wall-to-wall flounders right there. I don't know how many there are. And they're just as stunned as they can be. A crab of lying on top of two flounders, right?
那儿真的是全是比目鱼。我不知道有多少条。它们都晕得不能再晕了。一只螃蟹趴在两条比目鱼上，对吧？
Mr. Zundel is helping some friends who have never seen a jubilee before. He's advising them on how to use gigs, which are spears for impaling flounder, and how to gather crabs in a net.
尊德尔先生正在帮一些从未见过庆典的朋友。他建议他们如何使用叉子，那是用来刺比目鱼的长矛，以及如何用网捕捞螃蟹。
This is jubilee at its strongest. Here's flounders on the beach-- glitter you see on the war is fish. Just thousands of fish with the sun hitting them. Come stand out here and look at this. Good [UNINTELLIGIBLE].
这是庆典最强的时候。看看沙滩上的比目鱼——你在水里看到的闪光是鱼。只是成千上万条鱼，被阳光照着。站到这边来，看看这个。好[听不清]。
Mobile Bay is 32 miles by 8 miles. The eastern shore, where the jubilees occur, has a timeless feel to it. Some of the families have lived here since the 1800s, and several generations might share a cottage or group of cottages. A lot of the houses have sleeping porches, and some have real, actual white picket fences.
莫比尔湾长32英里，宽8英里。庆典发生的东岸有一种永恒的感觉。有些家庭自1800年代就住在这里，几代人可能共享一个小屋或一组小屋。许多房子有睡眠门廊，有些有真正的、真实的白色篱笆。
I learned about jubilees last summer when I was a bridesmaid in a wedding with two sisters named Murray Douglas and Marion MacPherson. They grew up on the bay, and Murray told me that from the age of five to the age of 15, she spent every night of the summer sleeping in her bathing suit on top of the covers, waiting for a jubilee. Basically, for ten whole years, she existed in a state of anticipation.
去年当我在默里·道格拉斯和马里昂·麦克弗森两姐妹的婚礼上当伴娘时，我了解到了庆典。她们在海湾边长大，默里告诉我，从五岁到十五岁，她夏天里的每个晚上都穿着泳衣睡在被子上，等待庆典。基本上，有整整十年，她处于一种期待的状态。
As I talked to Murray and Marion, I began to see jubilees as some sort of intersection of anticipation, inevitability, and luck. I decided to go down to Alabama to try to catch one for myself. When I got there, I discovered that everyone has a jubilee story.
当我和默里与马里昂交谈时，我开始把庆典看作是期待、必然性和运气的某种交汇。我决定去阿拉巴马州试着亲自抓一次。当我到那儿时，我发现每个人都有一个关于庆典的故事。
When the jubilees happen, of course, it's still early, early in the morning, and usually still very dark. So you go out in in your little shorty nightgown, and you know, your little babydoll pajamas, because it's so dark. And you're out there, and you're digging, and you're scooping, and all of a sudden, you realize it's broad daylight and you are out there in your pajamas. And then you kind of slink on back to the house and get your clothes on.
当庆典发生时，当然，还很早，还是凌晨，通常依然很黑。所以你穿着睡裙出去，你知道，穿着那种洋娃娃睡衣，因为天太黑了。你在那儿挖啊，捞啊，突然间，你意识到已经大白天了，而你还穿着睡衣。然后你有点溜回屋里把衣服穿上。
My favorite jubilee was when my husband and my son and I went down the beach just to flounder. And we come into a big jubilee then at Bailey's Creek, which is about a mile from here. One of the most biggest jubilees I have ever seen in my life. They were literally five and six lying on top of one another. You could get one and come up with five. When we got in that night, we had 720 big flounders. It was beautiful.
我最喜欢的一次庆典是我和丈夫、儿子去海滩专门抓比目鱼那次。然后我们在贝利河湾遇到了一个大庆典，离这儿大约一英里。我这辈子见过的最大的庆典之一。它们简直是五六条叠在一起。你能抓一条，上来就是五条。那天晚上我们进去时，我们有720条大比目鱼。太美了。
So I stayed and didn't go to work that day. Cleaned all of them, fileted them, put them in a little bag. Then three weeks later, Hurricane Frederick came, and we were 79 days without any electricity over here. So all those free flounders we got from the bay went right back to the bay. That's why I call it easy come, easy go.
所以我待在那儿，那天没去上班。把它们全清理干净，切成鱼片，装进小袋子。三周后，飓风“弗雷德里克”来了，我们断电了79天。所以我们从海湾得到的那些免费比目鱼又回到了海湾。所以我管它叫“来得容易，去得也快”。
It turns out there's a whole etiquette to jubilee. Some people say that a jubilee reveals who your real friends are. If you call people to alert them when you find one, they'll call you the next time. And if you don't do your share of patrolling the beach at 3 AM, you might find that your phone's not ringing as often.
原来庆典有一整套礼仪。有些人说庆典能看出谁是你的真朋友。如果你在发现庆典时打电话通知别人，他们下次就会打给你。如果你不承担凌晨3点巡视海滩的份额，你可能会发现你的电话没那么常响。
Also, it's totally acceptable to miss a day of work because you were up gigging flounders the night before and now you have to clean them. The only thing is, you have to bring in some flounder for your boss.
此外，因为前一天晚上在抓比目鱼，现在得清理它们而错过一天工作完全可以接受。唯一一点是，你得给你的老板带点比目鱼。
Down there. Ooh, did you see it? Yeah, it was down there.
在那儿。噢，你看到了吗？对，就在那儿。
I saw one!
我看到一条！
At night, around 10 o'clock, I go with Marion McPherson, whom I know from the wedding, her four year old son Skiddy, and their ten year old neighbor, Sayer Kerley to check the conditions. We've walked up the dock and now we're peering into the water with flashlights.
晚上10点左右，我和婚礼认识的马里昂·麦克弗森、她四岁的儿子斯基迪，还有他们十岁的邻居塞耶·克利去查看情况。我们走上码头，现在正用手电筒往水里窥视。
And believe it or not, there are more and more signs of an impending jubilee. We see a crab near the piling of the wharf and a few catfish.
信不信由你，越来越有发生庆典的迹象了。我们看到码头桩子附近有一只螃蟹，还有几条鲶鱼。
Ooh! They're all around there.
噢！它们都在那儿。
Jubilees believe can be several miles long or less than 100 feet. They can contain all sorts of fish or just one kind. For example, you can have an all-shrimp jubilee.
庆典可以有几英里长，也可以不到100英尺。它们可以包含各种鱼，也可以只有一种。例如，你可以有全虾庆典。
I thuink there might be a jubilee. Do you think there might be?
我想可能有庆典了。你觉得可能有吗？
There's at least three crabs on that [INAUDIBLE] over there.
那边的[听不清]上至少有三只螃蟹。
There's little fish, aren't there?
有小鱼，对吧？
Sayer says he thinks there's a seven in ten chance of a jubilee. Even though I'm really excited, I try to remember he's in fifth grade. I ask Marion to weigh in. I would say that really there are very good signs tonight. And this would be a night, if I-- well. This would be a night, if I were hunting jubilees, that I would sleep on the wharf and look for one.
塞耶说他认为有七成机会发生庆典。尽管我很兴奋，我试着提醒自己他才五年级。我请马里昂发表看法。我会说今晚真的迹象很好。而且如果是我的话——嗯。如果我在狩猎庆典，今晚我会睡在码头上等着看一个。
So I decided to sleep on the wharf. And I have some company.
所以我决定睡在码头上。我还有些伙伴。
I'm Sunny Kerley and I'm 14, and I'm about to go to sleep.
我是桑尼·克利，我14岁，我正准备睡觉。
Why are you on the wharf?
你为什么在码头上？
Because we're waiting for a jubilee.
因为我们在等庆典。
Are your parents making you do this?
你父母让你这么做的吗？
Ah, somewhat. Not really.
啊，算是吧。其实也不是。
No comment.
无可奉告。
Sayer is also sleeping on the wharf. Our plan is to get up every couple hours to see what's happening. I ask Sayer if he thinks we should set an alarm clock, but he says he'll be able to wake up without one. Before crawling into his sleeping bag, he drinks a Coke.
塞耶也睡在码头上。我们的计划是每隔几小时起来看看情况。我问塞耶他觉得我们需不需要定闹钟，但他说他不用也能醒。在爬进睡袋前，他喝了一杯可乐。
Less than fifteen minutes after saying goodnight, we have our first jubilee casualty. It's really buggy out, and Sunny decides to go sleep in his own bed. Sayer and I settle back down. But an hour later, we hear a noise.
说晚安后不到十五分钟，我们有了第一个庆典受害者。虫子实在太多，桑尼决定回去睡自己的床。塞耶和我又躺下了。但一小时后，我们听到一个声音。
OK. There's some mysterious thing that is floating with two lights in the front. Has a very loud generator engine on it. And it looks like he's catching some flounder, and we're going to go interview him, see what he's doing.
好。有个神秘的东西漂浮着，前面有两个灯。上面有个非常响的发电机引擎。看起来他正在抓比目鱼，我们要去采访他，看看他在干什么。
We've been here for like almost an hour. I did not come close to sleeping.
我们在这儿快一个小时了。我一点睡意都没有。
Neither did I. [UNINTELLIGIBLE] didn't do anything.
我也是。[听不清]什么也没干。
We walk to the shore to meet the boat coming in.
我们走回岸边去迎接那艘进来的船。
Hi. You think there's gonna be a jubilee?
嗨。你觉得会有庆典吗？
I don't know.  There's a lot of flounders out here, I know that.
我不知道。我知道这儿有很多比目鱼。
The guide tells us he's caught 50 flounder so far, which is more than twice as many as you'd get on a normal night. His plan is to stay out until morning hunting the jubilee, and he seems pretty sure that it's a matter of where, not if.
导游告诉我们他已经抓了50条比目鱼，这比平时多出一倍多。他的计划是待在外面直到早上寻找庆典，他看起来相当确定这是地点的问题，而不是会不会发生的问题。
After this excitement, Sayer and I go back to sleep and wake up a few hours later to check out the conditions.
这次兴奋之后，塞耶和我又去睡了一会儿，几小时后醒来查看情况。
Look where we're stepping.
看我们踩的地方。
We've established a routine Sayer fires up a flounder light and we walk about a half a mile down the beach. We're sloshing through the water and climbing underneath docks and over jetties. We don't find anything.
我们建立了一个规律，塞耶点亮一盏比目鱼灯，我们沿着海滩走了半英里。我们蹚着水，钻过码头下方，翻过防波堤。我们什么也没发现。
Sayer and I wake up for good around seven. There wasn't a jubilee, which is weirdly hard to believe. In my head, I had imagined the jubilee so clearly that at some point, it began to seem inevitable.
塞耶和我大约七点彻底醒了。没有发生庆典，这让人觉得奇怪地难以置信。在我脑海里，我已经如此清晰地想象了庆典，以至于在某个时刻，它开始显得不可避免。
Since I didn't get to see a real one, I decide to pay a visit to Manci's Antique Club, a nearby bar that has an entire wall covered with pictures of jubilees. I walk in and introduced myself to Mr. Manci, who immediately tells me there was a jubilee.
既然没能看到真的，我决定去参观一下附近的曼西古董俱乐部，一家墙上挂满了庆典照片的酒吧。我走进店里自我介绍给曼西先生，他立刻告诉我确实发生过一次庆典。
This was a big one, up in [UNINTELLIGIBLE]. It started at like seven o'clock in the morning.
这是个大庆典，在[听不清]上游。大约早上七点开始的。
I can't-- it was at seven o'clock in the morning? I was literally up at seven o'clock looking, but I was in the wrong place.
我不能——是在早上七点吗？我确实七点就醒着在找，但我找错地方了。
Well, you've go to be at the right spot at the right time.
好吧，你得在正确的时间出现在正确的地点。
Clearly I wasn't in the right place at the right time. But people console me by saying I have had the most authentic jubilee experience of all, which is the sort where you stay up all night chasing the jubilee, and you come close, but you don't actually find it. You invest all this time and excited energy, and then nothing happens. Of course, it's still fun to get excited.
很明显我没在正确的时间出现在正确的地点。但人们安慰我说，我已经获得了最正宗的庆典体验，就是那种你彻夜不眠追逐庆典，快要接近却没真正找到的那种。你投入了所有的时间和兴奋的精力，结果什么都没发生。当然，能感到兴奋依然很有趣。
To me, one of the coolest things about jubilee is that it's both unpredictable and good. I've been trying to think of other things that are like that, but it seems like there aren't that many. Usually stuff is unpredictable and bad, like a car accident, or predictable and good, like Christmas.
对我来说，关于庆典最酷的事情之一就是它既不可预测又美好。我一直试图想出其他类似的东西，但似乎没有那么多。通常事物是不可预测且糟糕的，比如车祸，或者是可预测且美好的，比如圣诞节。
While I'm in Alabama, I keep coming up with comparisons, but none of them are quite right. This is the one I finally hit on.
当我在阿拉巴马州时，我不停地想到各种比较，但没有一个完全准确。这是我最终得出的一个。
A jubilee is like hearing a song you love on the radio. Just like you can go out and buy shrimp at the grocery store, when I was 19 years old, I could have bought a Tom Petty CD and listened to "American Girl" anytime I wanted. But somehow it always sounded better when I was driving along in the car and it just came on. It sounded better when I was surprised by it.
庆典就像在广播里听到你喜欢的歌。就像我可以出去在杂货店买虾一样，我19岁时，我可以买一张汤姆·佩蒂的CD，随时随地听《美国女孩》。但不知怎么的，当我在车里开着车，它正好响起来的时候，总是听起来更好。当我被它惊喜时，感觉更好。
And even all the times you don't hear your favorite song, you still know that it exists in the world, that it's only a matter of time. It's not that big, but it gives you something to keep hoping for.
即使在那些你没听到最爱歌曲的时刻，你也知道它存在于这个世界上，只是时间问题。这虽然不是什么大事，但它给了你希望。
Curtis Sittenfeld is the author of the novel Prep.
柯蒂斯·西滕费尔德是小说《预科生》的作者。
Our program was produced today by Diane Cook and myself with Alex Blumberg, Wendy Dorr, Starlee Kine. This American Life's senior producer is Julie Snyder. Elizabeth Meister runs our website. Production help from Todd Bachmann and Stacy [? Titterington. ?]
我们的节目今天由黛安·库克和我制作，亚历克斯·布卢姆伯格、温迪·多尔、斯塔莉·基恩参与。本节目的高级制作人是朱莉·斯奈德。伊丽莎白·迈斯特负责我们的网站。托德·巴克曼和斯泰西·[？提特林顿]提供了制作协助。
[ACKNOWLEDGMENTS]
[致谢]
Our website, www.thisamericanlife.org, where you can listen to our shows for free. You can download today's show and our archives at audible.com/thisamericanlife.
我们的网站 www.thisamericanlife.org，你可以在那里免费收听我们的节目。你可以在 audible.com/thisamericanlife 下载今天的节目和我们的档案。
This American Life is distributed by Public Radio International.
《美国生活》由国际公共广播电台发行。
[FUNDING CREDITS]
[赞助商致谢]
WBEZ management oversight by Torey Malatia, who always says to me when he passes me in the hallway, particularly when I'm filing in the lower drawers,
WBEZ电台管理监督由托里·马拉蒂亚负责，当他在走廊经过我时，特别是当我正在处理底层抽屉的文件时，他总会对我说，
Hello, baby.
你好，宝贝。
I'm David Rakoff. Ira Glass will be back next week with more stories of This American Life.
我是大卫·拉科夫。伊拉·格拉斯下周将带着更多《美国生活》的故事回来。
PRI. Public Radio International.
PRI。国际公共广播电台。